-Our first guests tonight
are very funny comedians
and "New York Times"
best-selling writers.
The third season of their
fantastic show, "Desus & Mero,"
premieres January 31st
on Showtime.
Please welcome back to the show
Desus Nice and The Kid Mero!
How are you, gentlemen?
-Hey.
-Hey, Seth!
-Hey, Seth! Ha!
Good to be here.
-Thanks for having us back!
-Guys, it is --
it is so good to see you.
And I'm gonna ask you
the question
every talk-show host has asked.
How do you think
comedy will be affected
by the Biden administration?
And how have you felt
about the first week?
-Oh, I thought we were here
to do the new --
the new Chinese swab.
-You guys were
gonna do the swab?
-I thought that's --
That's what they told us
in the -- in the pre thing.
-We're not doing
the new Chinese swab!
-You're not gonna --
We're not doing that?
I was kind of
looking forward to it.
-We were --
If you were here in person.
But being remote, it would
have to be such a long swab.
-Yeah. An extendo.
[ Laughter ]
But so far --
I mean, so far, Biden --
You know, Biden's doing well.
It's like -- It's --
He's the new guy on the job.
He had to get
the WiFi passwords.
You know, he's still probably
fumigating the Oval Office.
People forget that when Trump
left, they stole a lot of stuff.
They might have stole
all the ethernet cable.
They might have took
all the silverware.
There's probably, like, keys
missing on the MacBook.
They're starting from scratch,
so, you know, give him
a little slack.
Give him a month at least.
-Yeah.
-And, Biden, he's got
a lot to do, like you said.
He's signing executive orders
at a breakneck pace.
You know what I mean? He's --
He's still Febrezing stuff.
You know what I mean?
Give him a little while
to, you know, mess up,
and then we'll --
"Yah!" Get him.
You know what I'm sayin'?
-I wanted to ask you guys
if you enjoyed watching
the inauguration,
especially because the Bronx
represented itself so well.
Not just with Sonia Sotomayor,
but with -- with Jennifer Lopez.
-Yes.
-With Queen J.Lo.
That's right.
You know what I'm saying?
Shout-out to Biden doing
inauguration the right way,
having actual guests,
having actual musicians
people wanted to see.
-Yes, absolutely!
-As a Bronx resident,
I got nervous 'cause I saw
the look in J.Lo's eyes.
She thought
she was back in Vegas.
She was about to go
into a rendition
of "Waiting For Tonight" or --
I don't know --
"I'm just Jenny from the block."
I know Secret Service was like,
"Enough. Enough. Turn it off."
-You know -- But, yeah, no.
Shout-out to J.Lo.
Her -- Her valiant attempt
to sing
was well-recognized.
You know what I'm saying?
The only thing missing
was that Versace dress.
-And shout-out to her sneaking
in that "Let's get loud."
That's what the nation needs.
We're gonna start putting that
on our currency.
"Let's get loud."
-♪ Let's get loud ♪
-How do you feel --
Are you optimistic
about the working relationship
between Vice President Harris
and President Biden?
-Mm-hmm. That should be
an easy -- That's a lay-up.
Especially because right now the
barometer -- the bar is so low.
It's like --
how bad can a presidential
and vice-president
relationship be?
The last president tried to have
the vice president murdered.
So as long as Joe Biden
doesn't do that,
I think everything
will be hunky-dory over there.
-They could slap-box
on Instagram Live,
and it would
still not be as bad.
-Well, so, you mentioned
both social media
and the insurrection
at the Capitol.
Are you surprised how easy
it's been for the FBI
to sort of find and apprehend
so many of these people,
who basically posted their --
their crime on --
on social media
as they were doing it?
-You know what?
They're saying that these people
don't believe
that blue lives matter.
Clearly they do because
they went out there to make it
as easy as possible
for blue lives to find them.
They tagged their posts.
They put on the GPS
on the videos.
They're doing -- They're
doing Braille translations
of some of their photos
just to make sure everyone
can see what they're doing.
It's -- It's mind-blowing.
-Bro, they were taking selfies
with the cops.
Like, "Hey, this is gonna --
Just so you remember,
this is me.
This is my face. My name
is Edward. Nice to meet you.
I'm gonna steal some stuff
from Pelosi's office."
-Yeah, it seemed like a lot
of those people, it was maybe
their first crime based on
how many mistakes they made.
-It was big high-school energy.
The first time you shoplifted,
and you're gonna document it.
"Look what I took from Sephora!
Oh, my God!
I'm out of control!"
Like, no!
"Grandma, get out the Capitol!"
-"I stole golf tees!
I don't even golf!"
-Hey, uh, speaking of golf,
how do you think life --
What do you think life is like
for former President Trump
right now in Mar-a-Lago?
-Miserable. Miserable.
'Cause he doesn't have Twitter
anymore.
That was his life.
That was his pride and joy.
Not his kids.
Not any of his hotels.
Twitter.
And now he has no Twitter.
He has all of these people
talking about him on TV.
He has no way
to get his opinion out.
Now he's that guy
that you avoid at every bar.
He's, like, kind of drunk
at the end of the bar,
and he has an opinion
that he's just saying out loud
that he wants somebody to hear,
but nobody wants to hear it.
He's probably
walking around Mar-a-Lago
just writing tweets
on, like, Post-It notes
and sticking them on random
places, hoping people find them.
-He's on the back nine right now
talking to an alligator
at Mar-a-Lago.
-He's like "Yo,
you see what Biden did?
He's terrible.
I was the best president ever."
-"Look at him,
look at him, look at him.
Don't you agree with me,
Mr. Chompers?
Biden's an awful leader.
He's not a real leader."
-Guys, what about a question --
Another question
we've all been asked.
People have said Donald Trump
was good for comedy.
Now that it's over, are you --
are you worried, or do you think
you're going to be just fine,
if not better?
-No, it's true.
-No. Now we actually
have to do our jobs.
We actually have to, like, study
and be comedians.
Before, it was like a lay-up
line. You know what I mean?
The warm-up
before the actual game.
'Cause it's such
low-hanging fruit.
This guy did something dumb
every 48 hours.
So now it's like, you know,
we have to actually,
you know, spread our wings.
-And that's why it's such a gift
when there's a new anal swab.
-That's right.
-Yeah. Boom! There you go.
-But you know what?
Honestly, the jig is up.
Trump has exposed that
late-night comedy is a fraud.
We meet up in the Slack with you
and Jimmy Fallon and everybody,
and we share
the same Trump jokes.
Now we're done. We're done!
Trump was pumping
the late-night industry
the same way Reddit
is doing GameStop.
I'm telling you!
-That's right. It's over for us.
It's like
"The Wolf of Wall Street."
It's all coming crashing down!
-If you see me on the street,
throw some change in my hat.